افادت مصادر قضائيه في تونس بان محكمه
تونس قضت بالسجن لمده اربعه اشهر في حق
سته عشر نقابيا في جامعه النقل التابعه
للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل ومن بين
هؤلاء وجيه الزيدي الكاتب العام للجامعه
وذلك على خلفيه شكوى تقدم بها وزير النقل
ضد عدد من نقابه الجامعه بتهمه تعطيل حريه
العمل واقتحام مكتب الوزير كما افاد موقع
الشعب نيوز تابع للاتحاد العام التونسي
لشغل بان النيابه العامه مددت ايقاف
نقابيين اثنين من وزاره الثقافه للرابع
والعشرين من الشهر الجاري على خلفيته شكوى
تقدمت بها وزيره الثقافه بتهمه تهجم عليها
خلال تحرك نقابي في الوزاره وهي تهملتي
لفتها نقابه موظفي وزاره الثقافه
من تونس تنضم الى مراسله الجزيره ميساء
الفطناسي وردود الفعل على هذه الاحكام
القضائيه في حق هؤلاء النقابيين
نعم عبد الصمد الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل لم يعلق الى حد الان على الاحكام
القضائيه الصادره بحق عدد من نقابه
التابعين لجامعه النقل علما انه قد يتجه
لاستئناف هذه الاحكام وهو ما يبطل نفاذ
هذه الاحكام ولكن ربما الاهم من هذه
القرارات القضائيه هو التبعاتها التي
ستنعكس على علاقه الاتحاد العامه التونسي
للشغل مع السلطه في ظل هذا الوضع المتوتر
والعلاقه المتوتره بين الطرفين منذ مده
حيث ان الاتحاد العامه التونسي للشغل وبعد
سلسله التحركات التي كان قد نفذها خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه وبعد التجمع العمالي
الكبير الذي نفذه ايضا في العاصمه كان اثر
اجتماع هيئته الاداريه قد اكد او مدد بما
وصفه باستهداف السلطه للعمل النقابي
وبتشويه الاتحاد التونسي للشغل
وحمل السلطه التنفيذيه ورئيس الجمهوريه
راسا قيس سعيد مسؤوليه كل ما ينجر عن هذه
التهديدات التي يتعرض اليها الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل ايضا من اوجه العلاقه
المتوتره بين السلطه والاتحاد هو ما يصفه
اتحاد الشغل بتنكر الحكومه
للاتفاقيات السابقه الموقعه بين الطرفين
وايضا من ابرز اوجه التوتر بين الطرفين هو
ما يعتبره الاتحاد العامه التونسي للشغل
غموض تفاصيل الاتفاق او تفاصيل الملف الذي
يعده تعده السلطه وتعدده الحكومه للتفاوض
مع صندوق النقد الدولي ويحذر الاتحاد في
هذا الصدد من التفويت في المؤسسات
العموميه كل هذا قد ينعكس على المبادره
مبادره لانقاذ التي يعدها الاتحاد العامه
التونسي للشغل والتي يقول اليوم بانها
طالت اكثر من اللازم ربما يعود ذلك الى
ضبابيه تعامل الاتحاد مع الطرف المقابل
الذي ستقدم اليه هذه المبادره في خطوته في
خطوه اولى وهو الرئيس قيس سعيد وفي ظل هذه
العلاقه المتوتره ربما قد يجد الاتحاد
صعوبه في توجيه مبادرته مبادره لانقاذ
للرئيس قيس سعيد شكرا لك ميساء الفطنسي
مراسلات الجزيره من تونس